welcome to this video yeah unfortunately
this is not the there was own final
because I got cancelled unfortunately so
on I want I just took another turn this
is a very small tournament but it's the
war zone format let's see what what
happens alright tournament is about to
about to start at least down the time
and for registration is up so it should
start
for some reason have no sound necessary
rotating and no Evan ok let's see you
two double forgot I got that again all
right yeah I'm a heavy favorite to to
win this but you never know then maybe a
couple of guys joining later yeah play
some pretty wacky stuff in those
tournaments to get a quick it conflict
going and win some some quick games
hopefully of course there's a huge risk
involved the bishop is hanging okay
sometime soon all those little things
can be can be tricky ok let's go forward
instead the tech oh he loved me to take
that this gets this get stuff now so
let's see um the mate I don't see you
made either so mate I can can do that
that's the easiest all right
let's see yeah I prefer to go you for
him and the astronomers yeah this looks
a bit strange but he needs to attend oh
he has got 95 are completely forgot that
then this was not not a correct play
okay it still as some as dangerous in
this time control right age 7 yeah
should I take here this maybe not come
out its material take it now exchange up
threatening see for now and the h-bomb
this is a very mighty porn
I want to promote it and keep the Queen
so this is quicker than just play g8
green can promote that right 303 we have
some late join us with a bit of a higher
rating so maybe someone can put up a
fight
all right come on start the game
110 players yeah they are so players on
the server but they somehow long changed
the regulations for the final so it
seems to be far less attractive compared
to compared to earlier tournaments I did
those wasn't finals regularly some time
ago but it's um it seems to be a dead
tournament and they still have those
technical issues it's really hard to
understand chest cube I mean play there
for like two years on and off and they
still cannot guarantee pack that games
are started this is very really strange
yeah this is a silly move really I could
have just taken you for now let's um
that's dangerous at least I've got a
poem and some nice play against h7 so I
go yeah pretty niche Falls is probably
stronger even
yeah this is hanging but I want I really
want to go for made Queen age for
Tillich eight snows came yeah for the
moment he has some talent everything I
need to economic Alliance f6 now and
Bishop d5
yeah this is a maid nope what the heck
rook age seven Andrew gauge one made yep
ya ali novel pious he's got also perfect
score yeah cannot take one after him but
close okay so let's get some some action
going here I have a target oh he's
ignoring this attack on f 2 this is very
accommodating known i def to what flag
is this actually Dominic can rap like a
very well-known country but I didn't
know the flag came five on five
i press this guy's close to 2000 now
it's still a very nice position for
white you should age 3 coming now he's
got 95 to to block it yeah but he cannot
cancel long with him
light takes c6 this is a quite quite a
big night night g7 97-95 threatening all
kinds of discovered discovered checks
and it cannot cannot really get out of
it let's go for it takes a five okay you
know how to how to win now g5g five okay
yeah five is hanging so it's not so so
easy I mean at least not was g5 k 1
cannot really a long night d 6 he does
allow it this wins lots of material with
a double check even
that's a meat okay six out of six and
four six wins straight away it straight
I got one rating point downloading yeah
I got a nice play along the eff file
this G for business is not really
helping wide at the moment that's just
this yeah for saying to didn't really
have a good square threatening night h3
now winning a piece I completely ignored
this and it's even more it's a piece now
and Bishop g4 would pick up an
additional exchange meaning a look in
total
look everyone I default would have won
the night but I was I just was too
focused and taking c2i ki can already do
fancy to anymore rockin don't let the
clock run down this is really not good
good to watch just get it over with and
start a new game maybe win a game
yeah Quint eggs and rock takes d5 Queen
txt five King be one night takes a three
the Sun is a false mate I think almost
King a one he can play which is yeah
what could be five this will also be a
maid analysis easier Quincy tuning find
the night ok seven out of seven clever
love our prices are no avail I'd see
maybe should have played one of my more
more regular openings this is more like
a bullet opening for me yeah i mean this
is a standard opening that white can
play but i'm not used to this position
let's see yeah I castled long intending
95 in a possible g-form its aggressive
but not necessarily good while usually
castles short in this position but long
castle system is a possibility is taking
some time this is a good sign not
dashing our turn moose instantly
yeah no g5 is something that he needs to
be cautious about g5 Night Moves Bishop
h7 this kind of stuff or come on playing
a tournament here some guys challenging
me to to play a game or not quite sure
what it is ok so when he's prepared the
age 5 square I see this night if he goes
97 yeah well I can i can just gain on
your space now is success hanging this
is the whole maneuver with Bishop EA
didn't help with the six pawn this was
my idea no maybe fy5 something like that
or g6 I can even just push this one g6
is a rather substantial threat now yes
but this is delaying ok m95 h6e I can
open up the position this must be right
and now i just need need something only
five like this and open a substantial
material ok 95 oh is that better move
yes this i was i was just thinking why
head well what's king g8 i thought he
must give material now and the sequin
play because of me just stupid
I mean stupid that I didn't see the
Queen g7 thing earlier this was the
whole idea of this operation okay we got
an Enzo here in the next game that's an
isolated Queen porn position White has
got the IQ p but healthy development
yeah be six is a move you need to be
cautious about sometimes this knight on
c6 can become an instant problem but i
think it's it's okay here mmm i can take
f3 why not now prepare a good square one
t5 hmm
yeah i can i can play nite nite f4 not
not sure I want to do that let's improve
it improve the position a bit more wow
look at this diagonal this is a very
very big double check and mate ok
accidentally a pity for not the end of
the world but I usually usually prefer
you for in those tournaments to to get
more dynamic play early but this is in
fact very nice yeah I can I can even
think about c6 here but let's continue
development it's a very nice position
anyway and here here's a problem with
the d7 I'd you know ye seven is saying
awesome I know my rock I need to take
first on eight I ever got to take haha
I forgot to take no ah ok so but like a
I still have to use seven porn it's not
not so clear 97 and c6 mmm yes I see but
I see six at least again
and I thought you would take okay let's
let's see if i can get the rook yeah so
now I'm a piece up again well I really
forgot to take on a this this was bad
yeah the sea problem is really my team
upstair mate don't see one at the moment
this one okay well this is a really big
lead now yeah the chi Goran she going
style quite an aggressive wake up play
for black very well suited for this type
of tournament let's hope your castle
short so that i can go nope hmm yeah
this is not a move to fear ok well i
can't take 25 i'm just playing on the c3
porn
yeah you really should take just going
for the activity group c 5 Bishop c5
this kind of moves hmm the queendom can
go to d3 okay let's increase the
pressure only three
hmm
yeah it's ready to play you for now but
not really I have Roxy five and then I
take you for what the heck I forgot
about them this what is this guy doing
to me this doesn't look good at all
taking f1 but it's not exactly difficult
to to fight I want 23 seconds what the
heck
two
yeah this wasn't so great giving give
you another pause and he's just taking
everything yeah come on where's this
really forgot to know what it's supposed
to the draw button what the heck I
really don't know what happened that I
mean I overlooked in 45 of course but
after this very strange opening this
vide really weird okay Naga three is not
exactly great against the Scandinavian
okay it's um in terms of the tone and
I'm nothing much happened the fun thing
is that I lost 13 points with this this
useless okay it's on again the recording
yeah I'm sorry I needed to pause it for
a note because my disk was full this
doesn't seem to be the luckiest
tournament ever I have received a
critical hard disk warning blah blah
whatever so I needed to delete some file
to get get normal space and come on I
cannot believe that there isn't a medium
come on okay well at least it should win
lots of material it's probably something
better
there's no midnight I don't see a maid
cannot believe it yeah i'm down to 30
seconds due to this damn hard disk
problem so this mod might get tricky
normally i think i would would do this
without much problem but a bit rusty in
the zone this interface yeah i think it
it's ok jung minutes
oops didn't even see that you can escape
okay yeah well this Lhasa I didn't
really have had the overall result of
the tournament but just a rather weird
okay so scratch rubbish on t3r the sky
is actually trading me very close well I
played I didn't take on c3 which was
completely ridiculous didn't refute his
opening which I should should have done
just Bishop d3 is just very bad yeah the
tournament is over out of time yeah I
die I wanted but I lost lost one game
this strange game with them where the
other guy just took off her pieces
alright so it was more of a
light-hearted affair then this sum
compared to those wars on finals which
really was one hour long fights but they
don't they don't have that anymore him
in this form at least so on I needed to
take some some other tournament and that
that's it alright i hope you enjoyed it
anyway thanks for watching and enjoy the
Christmastime right